[Music]
what's up guys in the home studio we are
talking about the secret lab magnus desk
today
uh the kind folksy culture said you want
to try this desk out and i said of
course i want to try this desk out i'm a
big fan of secret lab of course as you
can tell by the batman chair the dark
knight also have the titan chair in the
original color but i'm loving the omega
but we'll get into that later on this
review but i'm going to talk about this
table what i think about i've been using
it over the past three days in the home
studio setting it up with all my gear
so let's get down to it
[Music]
let's kick things off first off let's
talk about the design of this table it's
very simplistic when you look at it and
i think that's the kind of the vibe that
secret lab wanted to do with the magnus
it is a very streamlined look has a bit
more of a gamerish vibe than other desks
out there but again secret lab is meant
for gaming a lot of people love them for
that of course the comfortable chairs
but so it fits along that motif the
standout features of course is the way
that hides all of the cables i mean this
is something that we always battle with
in every electronic like cabinetry or
desk that we have is how do we hide the
cables
secret lab has found a way i like a lot
of what they did there are some things
that i wish they could improve on but
we'll talk about that later on so before
we get into things let's talk about
building and construction on this now i
didn't do a video of it being put
together but i did have someone from
secret lab come over here to set it up
for me um the instructions are very easy
to understand this is a very simple desk
to put together but because of the
weight i would recommend just for safety
to have two people uh work on this desk
to put it together you could do it on
your own
but two people is always safer
especially when you want to flip the
desk over this is a heavier desk also i
do recommend using some sort of power
drill to screw it and screw out the
bolts that you need to use because
um while they do give you tools to use
it
your fingers and wrists are going to get
some action but once it's put together
you're going to notice right off the bat
that this is a very solid feeling desk
now it is designed to be put against the
wall
normally how i use my desk is i use it
sort of in the middle of the room
because i use it for filming and i have
a camera that's in front of the desk and
it kind of shoots through it but as you
can tell by the design of it and there's
also bumpers that come with this where
you can get it as an accessory it's
designed to be against the wall case in
point get that nice uh reflection from
the lights from the rgb light strip in
the back of it and it really gives it a
nice kind of uh northern lights vibe to
the whole thing it's not overkill it's
just enough to give it a nice little
accent that gives that desk a much more
unique personality versus other desks
out there when we talk about the
tabletop here itself this is like a
laminated wood it's quite solid but it
is powder coated on top so it is quite
scratch resistant but the the lengths
here are metal there is a metal frame
underneath it that's really going to
help stabilize this table you do have
these nice red metallic accents on the
uh each of the legs right here with the
secret lab logo gives it a very sort of
gamer sporty look to this very
streamlined i like it i kind of wish
these were lit up but again that's you
know neither here nor there um but
overall i mean this is the 1.5 meter
version there's a 1.2 meter version
that's going to be coming out very soon
um the 1.5 is about 60 inches
thereabouts this is a nice decent size
uh for a desk out there i mean is it the
longest no i have a 72-inch desk myself
personally that i was using prior to
this and it would be nice if secret live
does come with a longer version of this
but i think for a lot of people out
there depending on your room size 1.5 is
sort of the um
that's this kind of the middle area the
safest place to go uh besides that
though i mean there is a little bit of
wobble as i've seen in the reviews but
it's not as bad as you may think i'm
case in point every table wobbles okay
when i sit next to it and i work i don't
feel anything moving around or any sort
of jittering around like that so there's
no issues at all with that now in terms
of adjustability on the desk this is not
an automated desk like other ones out
there where you press a button and goes
up or down you actually have to do this
manually with allen key and you can only
adjust it up to 20 millimeters on all
four legs now essentially this was
designed to sort of balance out the desk
if you're on uneven surfaces but it also
helps if you do want to raise it up a
little bit and two centimeters or 20
millimeters will make a significant
difference in terms of the height of
this desk i have raised it all the way
up i'm 1.83 meters six feet free
american folks out there like myself and
so it fits me just about right at the
highest level of that another thing
that's really cool if you have a secret
lab chair i'm not trying to sell you a
chair guys honestly speaking but if you
do have it you can actually kind of
move into this no issues at all it is
designed to work with the chair so if
you want to
raise up the arms the arms will come in
if you want to go down
it doesn't hit whatsoever very easy to
use if you're gaming if you're working
you can do that with the arms and you're
good to go one cool thing about the
design of this table is when you look at
it from the front it looks like the
tabletop is floating right there's
magnets that are keeping the table top
up but it's actually not it's very cool
um illusion construction here in
engineering because this is open right
here there are some areas here where
it's secure but what this allows you to
do is if you notice here on the side i
have two cables here i have an iphone
charging cable and i also have a usbc
cable i can run the cables from here
underneath the table coming out the side
and
it's very very streamlined
so
this is something that a lot of tables
have been struggling with over the years
is how to do cable management
secret lab i think has figured it out i
love this aspect to it because if i have
a lot of proof wheels i need to charge i
don't need to worry about cables
dangling off here or i'll go all over
the place i can just literally thread
them through here come up
and i'm good to go
and
you've got the badass magnets
do not put these on your refrigerator it
will dent your refrigerator trust me
these are very very tight here we need
an example see how tight that is
that's how strong these things are
and the magnets around the rest of this
table are just like that so
the magnetic top i think is a
beautiful way to keep your tabletop
without rolling or getting wrinkles or
any creases that you're going to get on
this because this is something that i
faced on other tables out there is that
whenever you put this mat on there
you know
over time it can warp a little bit it
can get out of shape just doesn't look
good over a longer period of time
secret lab has addresses with this
magnetic top and of course you have
these magnetic ends to it as well so it
really makes this secure a lot of you
might be wondering okay is it very thin
is it very thick if i am using a mouse
it's going to be it's going to impede my
movement on it no not at all this is
designed to be used for a mouse now i
don't use a mouse i use the trackpad
currently it's got a nice it feels very
like much like leather i know it's not
leather but it feels like leather so
you're getting that concept but it's got
a nice grain to it it looks very high
quality with the gold lettering so it is
it looks great i think this might be one
of the better things that they've done
with this desk outside of the cable
management because
you don't need to worry about scratching
your desk you can replace this anytime
you want and you have almost a brand new
looking desk if you think about it so if
this comes in reds or blues or
another logo out there which does come
in a few others but you can really
change the personality of this desk just
with this mat besides that though this
is a very simple desk now if you i do
use a mic once a while if i'm recording
any sort of content on my zoom f6 right
here i will put a mic here now you can't
put your mic clamp here on the side
because of the uh the depth of it here
but here it's very um shallow so you can
actually clamp it here no issues at all
bring the mic in and you're good to go
so let's talk about the back of this
desk because this is really where i
think the magic is in the magnus
desk in terms of its design and
engineering there's a lot of thought
being put into it now you do have this
bay back here where you can actually uh
lift it up and this is where all your
cable management is at now you have seen
this in a lot of the promo videos and
secret lab has done such a good job of
keeping it so clean you're like where do
you plug everything at you do need a
power strip to put in there okay or
unless you have some sort of other
peripherals or very long cables that you
can run up the leg and around the table
but you probably don't have those so you
will put a power strip there with
various different sockets and usb ports
and that's how i'm using it for my desk
now
in terms of there's a tray there where
you put all your cables you kind of just
kind of stuff it there you can wrap them
up and of course organize them but it
does allow to keep that back of the
table as minimal as possible which is
very nice because this has always been a
challenge on a lot of desks is how do
you keep the back of it looking as good
as the front because usually when you
look at the back of some people's desks
it's a very scary situation i'm sure
exactly as much as you have the back of
your desk it's a scary sight isn't it it
is it is right it is it is and then when
you have to unplug something and replug
something in you have to find the cables
and find out where it relates to
it is scary
this desk alleviates all of that so you
can actually manage it all through this
area so in terms of the bay door to the
cable management system if you're
worried about it scratching the wall do
not because when you lift it up it goes
perfectly 90 degrees so it's not going
to hit the wall at all even if your desk
is right up against it so that's also a
nice uh thought process that secret lab
has put into this to sort of make sure
everything looks good and it doesn't
damage your wall if you're having some
issues doing the cable management from
the top you can actually access the
cables underneath there is a magnetic
door underneath the desk you pull it off
you have complete access to say your
power strip there you can access your
plugs you can access other cables if you
want to run things through there you can
do so even if you want to run a cable
through there and put the door back on
it will do that because the magnets are
very very strong on the side of it it
latches that door into place so
this table is pretty much
magnet's galore if you haven't figured
that out by now
this is
all about magnets hence the name
magnus
also what they've done to highlight this
portion of it is put this magnetic rgb
strip here let me take this out so
actually this is what it looks like here
okay and you have magnets on one side
here that actually do stick and as you
can see this is flexible it's guarded
there's going to be no issues at all in
terms of safety
this is such a beautiful design honestly
even if you don't have the secret lab
desk
you can order this and put this
somewhere where else did you have a
magazine because this is really really
nice now you can actually put the strip
in the grooves here underneath the table
to kind of give you that glow at the
edges internally on this bait or you can
put on the back of it to kind of glow on
the wall besides that i mean the lights
on the back of it are not the brightest
lights you can uh change them based on
the controller of this so you can go
like rainbows you're seeing here you can
do solid colors you can dim it you can
do pulsating colors and
i mean in person it looks bright but on
camera as you're probably looking right
here it's not the brightest maybe secret
lab in the future could come out with a
more powerful lighting strip but there
are some things i do want to address in
terms of this lighting system it is
magnetic which is beautiful i haven't
seen that before instead of sticking it
on your table with glue or with tape
it's magnetic which is fantastic however
they don't let you know you need to plug
it in by a usb so you have to plug it
into some sort of power source it could
be a battery pack it could be your power
strip for your sockets that has a usb
ports in there that's what i've done
with this so i do wish secret lab would
have put let's say maybe some sort of
usb ports on the side of this or the
back of it to allow you to plug some of
those peripherals in there maybe they'll
do that in the future maybe they'll be
some sort of adapter that you can
magnetize to the desk and
do that but i love also the cable
management on the side of the leg here
as well this cable management is
something that secret lab has really
taken consideration not only the back
part but the leg so you can actually run
the cable down they have these magnetic
covers that match the design of the leg
so it makes it almost invisible so all
you do see is just a little bit of the
cable at the bottom plug into the wall
and that is it that's pretty much the
table it's seamless it's streamlined it
looks really good it can hold up to 200
pounds on this i have no issues at all
with the workflow on this there are a
couple things i do want to point out to
some of you out there that you may want
to take in consideration of just in case
that you run across this i did
personally i'm using a macbook pro now
the power brick that comes with the
macbook pro is pretty large
that power brick will not fit in the bay
of this magnus desk i've tried it in
various different angles it just won't
fit so i had to use another power
adapter or just plug it in through the
display here which i do normally do with
thunderbolt 3 plug it in here so i can
power up the laptop so if that is
something that you do have a very large
power brick for your computer or laptop
do take note of that
just have to find another variation to
that i mean i did talk to secret lab i
said why don't you guys make a larger
bay or a more deeper bay so you can put
more things inside of it and they are
taking this feedback back and kind of
looking we're looking if they can do
something like that in the near future
because again all these things it's a
very modular desk so when you buy this
you're not just stuck with one thing
you can really adapt this desk to be
what you want it to be which i think is
really cool by secret lab a lot of desks
are like that but i think that was
really one of the main attributes that
they were thinking about is making this
modular making it clean and making it
simple
i like their chairs as well so it all
kind of works uh homogeneously does that
work how much you'll see i gotta look
that up
yeah that's the desk in a nutshell i
mean there's really not much to say
about it it looks cool it looks the
business the price is really very
reasonable for what you're getting
you're getting high build quality from
secret lab on this the design is
fantastic um i can't wait to see what
they're coming out with various
different maps on this because i've got
the batman chair i think i need the
batman mat you know what i mean the big
bat logo in the middle secret lab if
you're watching
come on i need batman on my desk
it's very bad why am i doing that why am
i doing that to myself anyway those are
my thoughts on the magnus desk let me
know your thoughts in the comments
section below do you agree with me do
you disagree with me do you have any
comments or any questions you have on it
hit me up and i'll try to answer those
for you with that guys stay safe take
care and we'll chat to you soon
[Music]